his district so
okay let me be very clear and respectful
to you you asked me a question when I
answer it it's the answer to your
question you don't get to determine
whether I answer your question or not
okay in all respect thank you no no
let's answer her question
you just raised a question I'm gonna be
very clear with you the Intel committee
is different you know why because what
happens in the Intel committee you don't
know what happens in the Intel committee
although the secrets are going on in the
world
other members of Congress don't know
what did Adam Schiff do as the chairman
of the Intel committee what Adam Schiff
did use his power as a chairman and lie
to the American public I'll respect his
voters too and they'll serve on
committees but they will not serve on a
place that has National Security
relevance because Integrity matters to
me that's the answer to your question
this is what we've been waiting for from
Republicans for quite some time stand up
for the right things play ball